[Music]
you're are going broke so what do I do
win the M Ando or you are out of
business a th miles across bad roads
with sheep and dogs anything can happen
we have to win the Mia then orders for
sports cars will
follow everyone's eye will be on it only
one team will
win make sure it's
you the most famous race in Italy was
the be
media I'm entering five cars Collins
Ki the media was a Thousand Mile Race
Across open roads through mountains
through towns through aena to the
outskirts of
Rome back through bolognia all all the
way to brusso in the north where it
[Music]
began I've always loved this era in
Motorsports it's the most romantic
probably the most tragic and dangerous
period prear up until the 50s and the
Jet age now we're accustom to seeing big
crashes and drivers walking away in that
era they didn't and if they made made a
mistake it was usually
deadly this is an era in which the cars
particular Ferraris made a tremendous
amount of power everything in the
Ferraris was cutting edge but the racing
of the period was lethally
dangerous the mortality rate of the
spring team from 56 to 58 is about
50% so what possesses these men in the
Prime of their life to do something like
this make no mistake all of us are
racist that I have been we all are
certain it will never happen to me the
answer is belief that is never going to
happen to me and my friend is killed I
give up racing Forever on Monday I'm
back racing by Sunday but the addiction
puts you right back on that seat we all
know it's our deadly
passion our terrible
Joy
it's a meditation I think in many ways
because the speed is intense and focus
required you don't really think about
anything else so there's a cleansing
process of the Mind where you don't
listen to all the voices in your
head there's potential dangers at every
single turn okay go for it there's an
unknown that could happen at any moment
but how in the midst of someone who is
doing something incredibly dangerous do
you stay myopically focused on what
you're trying to
accomplish One race 1,000 miles across
open roads will determine some not all
of the issues that are colliding in
these 3 months of